yo bullet cat podcast bootleg kev show
man we got a special guest
the homie seti hendrix yo yo yo yo yo yo
what's up man what's happening what you
smoking on
oh what this is i don't even know what
this is some gas i got it from late
okay yeah um strictly backwards
we can smoke papers i'm smoking me some
papers i just was talking about that
like i need to get out backwards i was
gonna say would you ever make this like
the full-time switch
i'm ready for it i'm really ready i just
gotta learn to stuff him and roll him
how fat i like my backwoods yeah
yeah yeah yeah because you get those you
get those king sized cones though
yeah stuff them stuff them up man yeah
lowkey is a lot easier too if you just
get the cone because growing a backwood
is a process to be honest it's a process
but i've grown to like it
you know it's like an art form yeah it's
a heart i feel you man
sticking it you just look at that
[ __ ] like it's perfect well yo
you you obviously um
you're making a lot of noise man you
know i've been checking your [ __ ] out
for i want to say like a year year and a
half now
really i think ever since like i like i
saw john post about you 100. um
how long have you been making music give
us like a background where you're from
how long you've been making music kind
of you know
i've been making music by four years i'm
from jacksonville florida duvall county
duvall
and um yeah that's how long i've been
doing music about four years
not very long nah nah i've been with
them two years
so you you just picked it up and got
signed right almost right away
damn there yeah what was that what was
like the thing that like
kind of was on the uh radar of of of
draming them uh nothing
drama ain't no none about me he got
introduced to me
through my manager now willie joe okay
and before with a joke
it was me and my label my uncle florida
boy okay florida
music you know what i'm saying we kind
of came at them with you know i'm saying
that's what we got to offer jen now
i snuck in the studio too you snuck in
yeah i snuck before you were signed yeah
i snuck in main street
and i tried to get signed out chris
chris laundry he was at a
r for atlantic at the time wow and um uh
he gave me the run around you know what
i'm saying yeah man come on back give
you my car
all that i snuck back in here heard my
music willie joe heard my music
introduced me to john and then it just
went drum heard me
and was like if can he do it again
then got me in the studio for like two
three days and i came up with rules too
wow what they're like big man and the
rest is history
you know i lived in tampa for a few
years and
jacksonville is very much so um
its own thing yeah it's his own world
it's his own jungle like i don't know
like you know
living in tampa at central florida
everybody goes to orlando or they go to
miami or they go to fort myers or
wherever right we just nobody goes to
jacksonville yeah we over here we just
yeah little we're doing our own little
thing but it's that there's definitely
like
like like it's a very distinct place
because when
and also people from you know someone's
from jacksonville because they're so
[ __ ] proud of it
they scream yeah for sure for sure
904 facts man like talk about coming up
in jacksonville because you know i think
that
um there's a you know there's the city's
been kind of on fire low-key lately yeah
yeah um young and he's from jacksonville
right yeah there's some like dope
artists coming out of the city
papa that boy papa osiris yeah yeah um
and you know jets yeah man um i think
it's dope because like j dot
it's a couple it's a lot yeah man you
guys i feel like florida as a state has
got its way but the fact jacksonville
you know is kind of
what is it about the city that you think
kind of makes it special from everywhere
else in florida
man my city hungry to be honest
jacksonville hungry we've been hungry
for a long time
we've been overlooked for a long time
facts uh certain
certain people and certain things from
the city broke away and
scattered off and um we just feel like
it's our time to shine for everybody
always like you say nobody don't be
worried about duvall
we know about the city but we're known
for the wrong reasons
so it's like we all hungry man i feel
like it's a melting pot down there
there's different cultures down there
there's different music down there
there's different type of people down
there
like it's it's just it's a lot you got
to get brought to the light though we on
the way we got to get our head focused
though
it also feels like um i always have
people like
people joke that jacksonville is just
south georgia
because it's right there i don't know
why people would say that if anything
south georgia is florida
fair enough if anything fair enough how
we go up like how we
right right how we do that if y'all it
was that didn't make no sense
yeah i just think like i think that it's
it's definitely like a
it's gotta you know every everyone who i
know from jackson was very solid but
like i think
you know like you said there's a certain
hunger there's a certain like attitude
coming out of
that area the shelf was uh yeah shout
out to uh
you guys just got urban meyer as the
coach of the jaguars
which and the number one pick we always
get number one picks man we always but
this is always the year to get the
number one thing yeah this is the year
but
believe it or not you can look back bro
we always get raw
people like everybody be wrong ramsey we
getting picks and robbers all the time
we just need to know what to do with it
and i feel like we we cheated out our
last year before
we opposed with the patriots when they
were slapping hands with the referee
we were supposed to go to the super bowl
i mean we were supposed to go to that we
was up the whole game i was going to say
what is it like growing up a
jacksonville jaguars fan because i'm a
cardinals fan and it's rough i'm from
phoenix so
it's it's like an abusive relationship i
can imagine it's even more abusive to be
a jaguars fan
yeah it's just we just hope we hungry
that nigga's hungry too little boys
wrote it too like you can tell they
hungry like
we just want it real bad man growing up
with that jacksonville team like
we are so capable of getting the super
bowl we just hard hit it and we so
duvall
like it's to the point them they be
believing they from the city for real
like the players like
real for real they're getting braced for
show for joe for show for show um
talk about some of your influences man
cause i feel like your style is very
you can do you could rap you could do
this the melody [ __ ]
you know it's it's very much you got a
lot of uh a range
who who are some of your early
influences lauren hill
okay andre 3000 t.i
jay-z um trick daddy
jeezy trick daddy don't get enough love
man erica badu
uh and i grew up on a lot of el dorados
marvin gaye
uh you know i'm saying otis redding you
know i'm saying
the five blind boys at alabama my mama
had a whole variety of music
she never kept me um she never kept us
in close when it came to music it just
made us feel better
it was just music it makes sense though
yeah the way you the way you
you know the way you make your [ __ ] man
yeah for sofia that's um
have you ever been starstruck meeting
somebody
or somebody who you were just kind of
like maybe did you mention t.i
i'm assuming you met yeah yeah yeah yeah
i ain't been starstruck though
i i haven't been excited i'm gonna say
exciting oh yeah and i excited star trek
sounds like some hoe [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah i ain't stopped i haven't been
excited when i met when i met her
i was excited when i met t.i i was
excited um
i was excited when i met future okay uh
nah yeah yeah yeah it's it's mo
it's mo but i don't really see it as
thoughtstruck though just chilling
nah i i feel you i feel the same way
like you'll meet somebody like damn
who like i was excited to be at outcast
studio the other night
i'd just be in they went oh that just
shocked me this show that was this your
first time in line
man bro that was i was shocked when i
went there too i ain't never even met
big boy oh you walked through
it's like oh my god history he sat here
i remember my first time
going this before i even got signed my
first time going to florida but
um change took me there
and uh i walk in and they was like yeah
bro that's the pillow he used he passed
out on and
that's the couch and this [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm
grabbing this [ __ ] like damn this [ __ ]
this
old and i already love history you feel
me so to be in there like down looking
yeah up there with the [ __ ] who i
really
admire when it comes to the music [ __ ]
that was five nah yeah outcast is my
they're my favorite
they're like andre's top three for me
and
cast is the greatest rap group he
represented for the people in the south
showing him that we more than just shoot
him up bang bang dong's riding
i think it's dope that yeah like you
said like outcast
i kind of look at the way like tde and
kendrick is to la there you go
you know what i'm saying there you go
that's what outcast did for the south
first
you know so yeah i think you know what
tell me like what what what um
what are you doing in your spare time
man the pandemics are happening
there's so much [ __ ] there's been so
much random [ __ ] going on in the world
man
but there's definitely a lot more time
at the crib what are you doing in your
free time bro
i'm praying meditating i'm playing
basketball
i'm getting high i'm trying to work on
my relationship
talking to my mama a lot more just
staying grounded
you're in a relationship yeah okay yeah
just staying grounded
and um really just
staying in tune with the person that i
that i am and the person i'm trying to
grow into because 2020 that's really
what i feel like that year was a lot
about
yeah man there's so many distractions
there was so much [ __ ] going on
to the point where you had to stay in
tune with who you are and the people
that actually
care and genuinely love your family
because that was the year to actually
show
what it is everybody true hand was sean
everything that's some real [ __ ]
it's so cool you talked about meditating
i feel like uh there's like a very
weird stigma about meditating first of
all i don't think a lot of people
understand what it is
um yeah like i feel i feel like
i know what it is to meditate but i feel
like a lot of people
don't understand like the process of
what meditation they'd be thinking a
[ __ ] like
right now exactly like you got to be
like with some [ __ ]
with bongs and all that [ __ ] like a
shaman or
[Music]
but at the same time people get
meditating wrong because of their point
of view of what they've been raised on
mm-hmm to what this is
what they see on tv that's it that's
just what they and to be honest [ __ ]
don't watch t i don't watch tv
at all i don't i really don't watch tv
you don't binge watch nothing
i i'm i mean you may catch because i'm
in relation you may catch me on the
netflix right
ladies little [ __ ] like that but i'm not
watching tv how i used to watch tv you
know what i'm saying
so a lot of people shouldn't even be
appointed to meditating like that this
should be real life experience you know
you're going through to even want to
meditate it's too much [ __ ] in the world
going on right now
for people not to genuinely want to just
get some type of peace of mind
because obviously what you're doing
ain't working it's just what making sure
everything's silent
yeah and then just closing your eyes and
just just relax bruh breathe
breathe relax breathe and just inhale
exhale and appreciate
inhale exhale and appreciate that you
breathing that's fine that's that's the
start of meditation
that's the first start right there your
mind just goes yeah
and you gotta do the incense and all
that you can start it from right there
baby steps hey i know you're watching
the interview right now thank you for
watching we gotta interrupt this for a
special
uh announcement from our good good good
sponsors over at odd socks
i have all talks on my feet as we speak
these are nwo socks you know i mean the
wolf pack you know somehow
shout out to um odd socks though if
you're watching this
go to oddssocksofficial.com and buy the
most comfortable socks in the world
and i truly do mean that these right
here these are the most comfortable
socks in the world
these are the basics they're just plain
[ __ ] great
you know they got all the licenses
spongebob wwe
just everything you could ever want yeah
i mean i'm just throwing socks at nico
blitz right now our producer is filming
this
but uh look go to oddssoxofficial.com
trust me
they got the masks the boxers everything
you need
my personal favorite that i've been
loving is they got the naruto
and i'm not even into that [ __ ] but the
socks are fly and the street fighter
socks
crazy licenses oddsoxofficial.com
keyword
bootleg kev right now save 20 off at
checkout yo you talked about working on
your relationship
which i think is dope because i don't
feel i'm married but i don't feel like
we hear enough artists talking about
we either like see the the the really
good parts
on instagram yeah or it's the quiet it's
the
polar opposite but i mean every
relationship is worse this [ __ ]
real man this [ __ ] i been with my girl
my girl came along like right
like a year before i got signed mm-hmm
and i'm fresh out of jail
okay so she got the right to say like
shout out it was double fold your family
right
right right right and being in this
being a relationship and
coming up in the industry especially me
catering to women
you feel me i'm rhythmic gangster i can
go everywhere but my song low key came
out
towards women and to be dating the
family so it's just like damn man
but you got to grow with it certain [ __ ]
you just gotta grow with you gotta stick
and move and hope that you understand
what you signing up for
mm-hmm and and give them a whole idea
and lay everything out man that'd be the
problem with [ __ ]
um nobody telling what you finished
signing for uh oh
like i've always tried to take the
approach of like because
i've been through so many [ __ ]
relationships it's like you you never
want to stop dating your girl
you never want to stop dating her if
that makes sense
like they stop the energy that you guys
have when y'all were dating
you know what i'm saying or when you
guys first started talking to each other
you kind of like you
like always want to make you got to be
kept because i don't
i feel when you we talking we dating i
grew up like
i don't even mean like i don't even mean
like going on dates i just mean like
that energy like
i ain't even saying days i'm saying like
the moment we the moment
me and you say oh yeah we talking we
texting all that yeah
yeah everybody else cut off on your yeah
yeah we
in this hey man not a lot of people
share that sentiment for sure
i don't need to be playing like that
it's like yo if i'm taking the time out
to give you my energy yeah
this is special yeah that's fair you
said you mentioned you went to jail
what'd you get locked up for you don't
mind talking about it
oh what time which time uh
how about the longest time longest time
was the last time i said possession of a
firearm about adjudicated lincoln
uh possession of more than 28 grams uh
fight all that extra [ __ ] driving
without lights i've never in my life
ever had a license
so i i went through all of my 20s with
no car insurance yeah just
slides you get the ticket you know go
pay for it a month
you know get the ticket squashed and
then just let that [ __ ] run no no
never my life had a license man you
still don't have a car
driver's license is there
like is it just you just don't want to
go to the dmv i've been too busy
and i know that maybe like [ __ ] ain't
never too busy hit your head down
someone go but
man listen i'll be too busy i'll have
other [ __ ] to do
i need an assistant there should be no
reason why i don't got my license right
now damn you right
yeah like right like how old are you i'm
12 i'll be 25 january 20. yeah you gotta
you know
yeah i gotta get him i gotta get him i'm
[ __ ] it's just a piece of mind you
know if you're whipping
you know even if you go even if you're
hitting the quick trip it's so
you might get pulled over you ain't got
your lights like ah and that's the main
reason why i got [ __ ] up so many times
pulled over and all that other [ __ ]
cause i ain't got no license so now that
i get them folks the right to search and
weed and all that extra [ __ ]
yeah it's crazy because in florida and
you know
being in la i'm so used to like
marijuana just being um
it's just like cigarettes yeah and like
i was
i was about to just light up in the club
the other night out here and my boy was
like no no no no
tied up in the club you could light up
in the club now that where we was at we
was at a
we were at one of the more whacker strip
clubs oh okay it was called pink pony a
strip club
pink you can't smoke in there yeah i
don't know we went to some place
yeah but yeah they were like he was like
nah no no he's like this ain't like
i was like what the [ __ ] that's crazy
yeah
i think like you know hopefully
everything's federally yeah anyway i
can't smoke i'll try not to go
that's fair yeah where's the craziest
place you've smoked
uh what's the little things that you
when you snowboarding that you go up on
oh the the ski lift this is crazy so far
that's been the craziest
place my man went on the ski lift yeah
um all right so
say less is out going up you got some
crazy features
g herbo gonna obviously the home team
um jack um hey boogie
um which one of those records or which
one of those features
um was the funnest to make because you
know nowadays and i don't know if any of
them were ins like were you in
in person with with the artist yeah only
only ones i went in person with was uh
herb and gunner every every other
feature i had already a year prior like
i been had
so but so which ones were you in in like
in the studio with
boogie 24 so all the other ones all the
other ones yeah okay okay
yeah i was gonna say like what was the
best studio session for first for say
less
[Music]
the best one i have to say was with me
and
yeah i have to say me a boogie
yeah a boogie is very uh hey yo he's
he's a he's crazy with these melodies
i'll be telling people he you know i
mean he's so big on this side like the
michael jackson he's crazy like
michael jackson with the melody's crazy
man
yeah he's crazy who's like what do you
listen to right now when we talked about
your influences but like
who are the artists that like that are
in your regular rotation
hmm why listen to on a regular uh
right now
[Music]
damn i don't want to sound biased but i
really be listening to me
jack harlow well jack harlow's album is
[ __ ] incredible just crazy
um highway 2009
uh who else
and i've been listening to a lot of old
school music some old school [ __ ]
like i didn't dab in the new in the new
music that's how i feel like if you
listen to too much of the new [ __ ] as an
artist you can't help but be informed i
really it really got to get put in my
face while i be in the club or i really
got to catch it for me
have you ever caught yourself like
listening to some [ __ ] too much and then
like
you almost subconsciously become
influenced by it yeah
of course all the time with a lot of
music that's how they do it out here
that's how they that's how they push it
in the world now like
it's a lot of music nine days there's so
much music a lot of music you're not
manually just clicking going to go like
oh i'm feeling
this [ __ ] i heard this let me go nah let
me it just comes on it just comes on and
you hear you be like damn bro
what's that song i heard or what's that
song we was your family
i hear that all the time um you know
being signed to generation now
one of the hottest labels obviously um
you know drama and and canon and lake
are legends for sure gatekeepers
gatekeepers for sure
um and like what i appreciate about
everybody even you know going back to
uzi is just the groundwork every artist
has put in like
jack like people act like jack harlow's
a new artist hate when they hate when
they
act like this was overnight like my
man's got so many projects out he's been
hitting every freestyle and radio [ __ ]
like this guy's been doing this thing
for three
three years you know himself and the
same thing with you like you've been
putting in work like
it's it's not there's not a magic switch
that gets hit over here i love that
and i love that i love the fact that
they actually let us grind and put in
as bad as we come over here and they be
on the what's up how's it going working
you think it's going to be a magical
switch because of who they
are and you get over here and you go
through boot camp and be like damn jim
now really on some old
i see how they make stars i see how it
happens because
you really finna put this work in yeah
we the gatekeepers but you finna make
this key
it's about to yeah it's about the work
yeah i was going to say like what is um
what it what what's what's like you know
you
you have a relationship with guys like
drama and don cannon that not a lot of
people have
yeah um what is it like you know being
signed to them
and having them as mentors and people
that are like like helping
guide your career it's great it's great
man
it's an awesome feeling because i called
it i manifested it
i mean i had jail have stories on this
when i was in jail i told i told [ __ ]
i was like man when i get out bro i'm
gonna sign the drama drama gonna sign me
i'm gonna go on tour
i'm feeling that out of the dish and all
that and i actually end up getting out
of jail
you know what i'm saying and making the
move happen
get shoot to my mama house break my mom
off something i slide to the air and i
actually make this happen
i mean yeah you snuck in bruh yeah you
literally made it happily made it happen
it couldn't win we could have went left
working with them and being with them
and having a relationship with the
people that
some people die to have but some people
only dream to have is like
i don't take it for advantage at all
it's a blessing yeah i think like um
i said this on twitter instagram
when the uh gucci and um jeezy
verses happen i was like dramas i
look at drama as the most influential
greatest hip-hop dj to ever live
like i'm not saying he's the best at
scratching and tricks and all that i've
been we're talking about influence yeah
and touching the culture we talk about
what matters that's all
like he's the greatest yeah like nobody
can even hold a flame to him and i'm
sorry
that's over jam master jay that's over
everybody like show you what you're
right you're right man you got to think
about this man like
just me growing for a person that's
staying this long
what 10 15 years not still yeah to last
that long
in the game like you ain't got nothing
to talk about you got to know this man
the best this man still
blowing people that we're listening to
right now yeah to this day
do you have any relationship with uzi at
all
no not at all but the crazy thing about
it
it's this clip that i got on my
instagram
it's in my archive i ain't gonna post it
yet i don't know if i'm ever posted
again
but um he was in the b room that's when
he had purple hell
yep i'm in jacksonville now right i had
a song called uber everywhere shout out
24 hours yeah he's on my tape his
brother made it
tokyo yep i didn't know none of this
at the time he ended up
i ended up you know two white is this
the white boy my boy slim
and my and my boy tom they end up
sliding up here
to atlanta trying to make something
happen
hey uzi end up playing my song the uber
everywhere
i put them i don't know if slim put it
on or uzi put it on
they play it and i got the video they
didn't they in the studio vibe and
listening to it it's in the b
room huh wow and uh
fast forward later he come to the city
and performed
with herb mod squad now and uzi
you know dj shadpat brought him to the
um brought him to uh florida theater
and then from there fast forward now i'm
in the same building sign to the same
label like
i'm saying like that's crazy yeah i'm
saying so no i don't have a relationship
with them but
to have that moment right there when
they get brought back up the light
with this interview get out of heaven i
just wonder how that's going to play
back when everything's said and done
that's fire that's crazy that's big man
yeah that's uh everything went full full
circle right everything's been going
so you saw i mean did you and you saw
that video then when it happened yeah
yeah it went on twitter this [ __ ] was
going crazy i ain't have a toilet at a
time i ain't no nothing about that like
yeah
i didn't get it i didn't get hit to the
internet to 2015.
i didn't know how to work at gmail or
nothing jesus man we gotta get you a
license
i promise i got an iphone i just you
know i just i don't know
you can't legally drive a car so i gotta
ask you know what i'm saying
anyway well look man i appreciate you
checking in um what is next for you
because obviously it's a new year
the project is out but like what's
what's on the horizon
um we finna drop these visuals man be
prepared for these big big big
big visuals that's all i got to say we
finna dry i said lester to the ground
and then i got rhythm and gangsta man i
got the album coming rhythm and gangster
yeah you know there was a snoop dogg
album i know that called rhythm and yeah
guys definition rmg and um it's either
gonna be called rhythmic gangster
or therapy therapy okay i like that yeah
this year yes yeah this year boom seti
hendrix man bullet calf